[Applaus]
der Boulevard hat es dann auch gleich befeuert
der murgsminister so steuert uns Habeck in den
Blackout das war auch in diesem Jahr
so es geht ja egal bei wem nur noch um
Schlagzeilen nur noch schnell eine reißerische
raushauen Klickzahlen generieren kalte Keule
aus Sibirien neue Geheimwaffe von Putin werden
wir jetzt alle noch länger im Dunklen erfrieren
Omegon mit seinem sanften verlaufen wir
doch niemanden mehr hinterm panikofen
her wir brauchen was griffiges auf
einmal hieß es jetzt kommt die Omi
kommt nicht
weil sie nicht laufen kann und ausgerechnet der
Söder hat dann gemeint ist die Sache die Tür
so was ist denn was war denn eigentlich was ist
denn mit dem also was war denn mit dem eigentlich
in diesem Jahr was ist mit dem an das mit ihm das
was mit ihm immer los ist mir egal Hauptsache ich
bin Erster in die Schlagzeilen und es war ja weil
dauernd kam Söder fordert Söder verlangt Söder
will Söhne er braucht ja auch eine nächsten ja
Landtagswahl da musste alles was ich Legalisierung
von Cannabis war nicht witziger bei den Lauterbach
von Tal angegangen es ist unglaublich vor Corona
zu warnen und es kiffen zu erlauben da
hat Gewittern aber schlagfertig reagiert
für mich ist es unglaubwürdig vor Cannabis zu
waren und sich gleichzeitig ungeschützt auf
dem Oktoberfest ins Koma zu saufen
aber immer das kommt er der Söhne
bei Söder war immer nur draufhauen das
hat kein Land der Welt ist glücklich
waren mit der Freigabe von Drogen und in
Berliner Grünen reicht die Legalisierung
von Cannabis ja gar nicht da muss jetzt
auch noch Kokain her und Christel mit
und der so gesagt schon bisschen Crystal Meth gut
der Mittelfranke tut sich schwer mit dem TH aber
ich habe mit einer Crystal Meth was soll
das jetzt sein rohes Schweinehack als neue
Modedroge [Applaus] christliches Mett gibt es
in der Apotheke dann als Ersatzdroge mit Adobe
ist es mit der bundeshackfleischverordnung
überhaupt vereinbar oder geht es um eine Frau
bei dieser Crystal Meth vielleicht
die Cousine von Digital Robert
ich habe nur noch auf den Satz gewartet mit
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das ist die
Einstich Droge für schwere Schweinshaxen das
öffnet die Tür für cholesterin-missbraucht
tut er hat mir gleich
okay
er hat sie leicht na weil sein Personal da
merkt man mittlerweile schon dass also der
Fachkräftemangel überall durchschlägt gegen
seinen scheuer ermittelt seit diesem Jahr
der Staatsanwalt muss ein Generalsekretär der
Huber das ist auch schon der dritte in diesem
Jahr den hatten sie auch gleich am Haken wegen
seines Doktor Titels und seine Doktorarbeit aber
er hat sie noch verteidigt ich habe doch
den Gutenberg extra noch rum Rat gefragt
Titel trotzdem Weg der Huber noch da dann der
Untersuchungsausschuss Maske der wird dem Söder
noch bis zur Landtagswahl um den Hals tandlern
und sein Mann in Brüssel hat dann auch schwer
gepatzt Manfred Weber der Chef der EVP der Chef
der christlich konservativen wertefamilie lässt
sich vor der Wahl in Italien mit der Partei
von diesem Untoten nein Silvio Berlusconi
also ersten gemeinsamer Fernsehspot und dann
einen forsches Foto für dessen Partei Forza Italia
was euer ewiges Idol Franz-Josef Strauß mal gesagt
hatte dass man mit solchen Leuten nicht paktieren
darf denn Recht von uns ist die Wand und dann
hat der Weber die Tür in der Wand entdeckt
da war sogar
da war der Sohn der Sauer also der Türsteher das
sagt ja Manfred natürlich brauchen wir Bilder der
kein Inhalte hat als Partei der braucht Bilder
aber dann ist solche schöne und schöne Bilder
die hat er bekommen der Söder im Sommer beim
G7 Gipfel in Schloss Elmau meine Güte war das
eine peinliche Inszenierung und die Staats-
und Regierungschefs flogen ein und wurden in
München abgeholt am Flughafen von indigenen
Gebirgsschützen und Blaskapellen mit Hund da
und Lederhosen auf dem Rollfeld erschienen als
erstes Joe Biden der kam direkt aus Berlin nun
wird sich gedacht haben ach so geht also Provinz
macron seine Brigitte sind ganz schnell an den
Kampfsport Zombies vorbei wir kennen diese
Leute nicht wir können diese Leute nicht
der japanische premier ist dann erstmal
minutenlang auf dem Teppich hat Fotos
gemacht und dann kam aus Italien noch Draghi
und hat gemeint ah ist das schon der Oktoberfest
und mittendrin immer dabei Markus Söder
in voller Montur also in Niedertracht und
da ich mich abgefahren
darf ich mich auch gefragt also wenn ein
Mittelfranke wieder Söder oberbayerische Tracht
trägt ist es jetzt kulturelle Aneignung eigentlich
schon ne man muss doch heute so aufpassen was tut
man was sagt man was macht man eine redet und Ding
und stimmt es und dann ist es wenn du was sagst
auch richtig geändert das mit dem gender ist für
mich also für mich als alten weißen Mann ich tue
mir das so schwer damit ich ihn ständigen dieses
Boot mit meiner Tochter die ist Ende 20 und für
die Generation ist das wahnsinnig wichtig wenn wir
so dann in Ding dann sagt sie immer mehr Papa für
uns ist das mit dem Gendern heute eben das was
das mit gegen Atomkraft sein früher für euch war
so ja klar
ja ja praktisch passt das gleiche
ist für euch ja auch schwierig wo wollt ihr
die ganzen Silben entlagern das ist echt nicht